mic triplet covering the Saints for ESPN
and he joins us on the program Mike
how's morale Dan it's been a long time
since since you've had me down after a
Saints game I can't imagine what would
have transpired who call this morning
morale is is not good but at least it's
more anger than disappointment I mean
the Saints now the Saints in the city of
New Orleans now has some of the more
spectacular ways to end a season in
heartbreaking fashion to compare them
all but this one's a little more angry
than I think the Minnesota miracle
reaction was a year ago do you think
that the non-call is overshadowing a lot
of other things that transpired in this
game if you're a Saints fan I look at it
and say there are a lot of missed
opportunities here I can question some
of Sean Payton's play calling but you
know it feels like you know I know that
past interference play is gonna loom
large and hang there for a long long
time but I thought that there was some
there were some issues with the same
certainly on offense the last six weeks
of the season well that's of course I
mean you put yourself in a position that
one call can lose a game for you that
means you didn't do enough to put it
away especially when winning 13 nothing
and won the overtime coin toss but I
mean yeah we'll see what hindsight says
but this has the makings of us sitting
here talking about how you know Chris
Webber's wouldn't have mattered if
Michigan it scored more early in the
game or you know miner had scored a
couple more touchdowns in the first half
nobody would mother's ball so but also
you know with the non-call you know did
your receivers sell it well enough when
he's on the ground and he popped up and
went back to the huddle like he didn't
seem bothered by the non call and I said
there's three missed penalties it's past
interference it's defenseless receiver
and it's helmet-to-helmet
other than that you got the call right
yeah well it's funny because I mean
maybe you nine state each you to tried
to sell it more but that one felt
obviously like one that didn't need any
selling I mean I know everybody up in
the press
box was was looking for now which guy
throws the flag in this situation even
Nikhil Coleman was like yeah I knew it
knocking him over was better than giving
up the touchdown and when I got up I was
looking for the flag and he was as
shocked as anyone that he didn't get one
was any official made available after
the game last night yeah the head
referee was the only one who talked
after the game to the media as a pool
report and he said he had not had a
chance to make the call which was
unfortunate obviously so no detailed
explanation came from the crew itself
and that obviously we the head of NFL
officials is the one who prevail on is
the one who called Sean Payton and so we
got our best explanation of how the
being felt about the call Sean Payton
himself and he made it clear that the
league admitted that they blew the call
at both infractions should have been
called the tion whatever I was there a
tipped ball on that play at all no and
not that I saw and even Nicol Roby
Coleman from what I read said at first
that an official told him that there was
a tipped ball or that's why they didn't
throw the flag but then at least one
report I saw Roby Coleman later said
well actually it was one of my teammates
I don't think a tipped ball was part of
part of that controversy was just a
missed call and look you were right
earlier you said you know it's not the
only reason they lost the game it was
one bad play you got to make sure you
know you don't put yourself in a
position for that one bad play to cost
it but but nothing that bails the
officials out of that situation that's
probably what you know one of the more
memorable missed calls in sports history
I already saw comparisons to the World
Series call at first base last night I
don't live on that law but it's in that
ballpark
I guess foregone conclusion Drew Brees
is back probably I definitely think and
things like that but you know I can't
imagine
that we've on this one his last pass
being an interception unfortunately
obviously something else that you know
was one of those things that could have
changed the outcome but also he played
great this year and he's coming back to
a team that is still built to win if
they can give us Sean Payton I know he's
under contract but we assume he's back
yeah I mean I see no reason I see no
reason to change that while I got this
this nucleuses young talent you know
special you know we always talk about
two quarterbacks being a good way to
build a good team like Carson Wentz and
Russell Wilson the Saints have chief
everything else besides a quarterback
with guys like Michael Thomas and Alan
Chimera Marshawn Lattimore on their
rookie contracts they're going to go
into next year is probably the favorites
in the NFC but this year proved that
being the number one seed doesn't
guarantee you anything I'm looking at
the competition committee the NFL
Commissioner selects the members of the
competition committee so you have two
owners two club presidents two general
managers and you have two head coaches
and one of those head coaches is Sean
Payton I'd love to be at that meeting
Mike as Sean Payton talks about the
competition committee and how do we
better officiate again if we have the
technology and I brought this up earlier
and I don't know if this is a topic for
another day but if you have Mission
Control and I have the head of the
officials who is watching this who knows
they've missed the call has the
technology to be in touch with the head
of the officials is there scenario where
you could see this put into play at some
point and and what plays are going to be
reviewable or changeable yeah well look
this has been a big topic long before
this and Sean Payton himself was a big
advocate for it I just tweeted out a
story from two years ago where I
remember the famous Richard Sherman pass
interference or no call that made this a
big controversy Sean Payton great a
strong plea that pass interference
should be reviewable and they've
actually toyed with that in Canada and I
think the CFL championship was decided
by reversed egregious pass interference
call I know love to say I don't need
more replay reviews but getting it right
is more important than some delay that
you know and in this situation
I think you'd be hard-pressed to find a
fan now with the weight wanted away 90
seconds so them to get that call right I
I think there will at least be a push
toward pass interference being
reviewable call because it's the
sometimes the biggest penalty in sports
when you're talking about you know 30 or
50 yard pass interference Valley's Mike
thanks for joining us good to have you
back we appreciate your time thanks for
joining us
Anna Dante that's Mike Triplett ESPN
Saints reporter for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]